iran is accusing israel and promising
revenge for the ambush shooting death of
a top scientist who has been described
as a key figure behind iran's nuclear
bomb program
almost two decades ago the attack
happened on friday in a suburb of tehran
the capital
roxanna saberi is in our london bureau
with the latest roxanna good morning
good morning dana iran's supreme leader
ali hominy is calling for the assassins
to be
punished iran's president is also
promising revenge while blaming
israel for the attack the comments come
a day after mossein factory zade was
killed in broad daylight while traveling
near tehran
iran's defense minister said the car
carrying the scientists was shot at
before a truck bomb exploded nearby iran
says factory zadeh was a college
professor but the u.s and israel have
alleged he led a secret nuclear arms
program
and in 2018 prime minister benjamin
netanyahu singled out factory zadah in a
news conference
accusing him of conducting nuclear
weapons work under the guise of a
civilian program
israel has not yet commented on
yesterday's attack but iran has accused
it of killing other nuclear scientists
in the past decade
whoever killed factory zonda his death
is likely to raise tensions
between washington and tehran earlier
this month president trump reportedly
asked senior advisors
about options to attack iran's main
nuclear site but was dissuaded
neither the white house nor the biden
transition team has commented yet on
yesterday's killing but president-elect
biden has suggested
he'll rejoin an international nuclear
deal that president trump left
in 2018. ed roxanna thanks